this week's been one to celebrate women
with international women's day on
tuesday it's a time to recognize the
achievements of women around the world
in politics it's been and often still is
a fight to get women's voices hard and
one of the women who's been leading that
fight in british politics for four
decades is labour mp harriet harman
she's the mother of the house of commons
which means she's the longest serving
female mp still sitting and earlier i
spoke to her in her first television
interview since announcing her
retirement
harriet thanks for coming on the show
you became an mp in 1982 and it was
against the backdrop of mass protest
against nuclear weapons the women at
greenham common it ended up with
thousands of people protesting across
the uk
and now as you prepare to stand down as
an mp
40 plus years on
we've got this moment where president
putin has put his nuclear weapons back
on alert
and i wondered what that made you think
as if we've gone back 40 years back to
the cold war back to a world that we
thought maybe was in our past
well i think that the path we've tried
to go on since then is to stop the
proliferation
of nuclear weapons of having more and
more countries becoming nuclear
countries and to reduce the
nuclear arsenal of those those
superpowers that did have nuclear
weapons but it is one of the most
frightening in amongst the horrific
things that's
happened with putin's invasion and
harriet you've been a lifelong supporter
of labor labour values of
internationalism what do you think's the
principal position to take on ukraine
that they should fight tooth and nail to
liberate their country that there should
be an immediate ceasefire and talks
leading to a compromise what should we
be doing well i think what we should be
doing is what we are doing which is
saying that they are absolutely right
and entitled to defend themselves and
putin is absolutely wrong to invade we
just have to be absolutely clear about
that
and do everything we can to support them
in in their fight against putin which is
a defense of themselves a war that as
president zielinski said to us in the
house of commons yesterday a war that
they did not start and they did not want
what was it like in the commons
yesterday
well
it was a bit chilling really because it
it it drew to your attention how
how safe and secure we are in the house
of commons in london
in the uk and we saw president zielinski
in such a position of jeopardy with
hundreds if not thousands of his people
being killed and millions fleeing under
attack from
from a nuclear power i think it just
showed the stark contrast and harriet um
you obviously support sarkir stama's
position but it has stoke division in
the party 11 mps signed electrocutes in
nature of sabre rattling and then
kierstarma threatened those mps with
suspension
labor's always been a broad church do
you think it was a bit aggressive
to sort of threaten people with
suspension oh not at all i think that if
you're the leader you have to have a
clear position and you need to make sure
the party has a clear position and the
labour party does have a clear position
which is we support nato and we support
ukraine and we couldn't have people who
were labour mps somehow qualifying that
so i think he was right i mean one of
the things about leadership is yes
listen to and include a broad range of
views but in this sort of situation you
have to be decisive and that's what he
was the reason i wanted to get you on
the show was it was international
women's
day
this week you have been
the most prominent feminist campaigner
in politics from for many decades
actually
um you're the longest servant female mp
you're the true trailblazer and i
remember a few years back when i was
talking to a conservative mp about
getting more conservative women on the
benches they said we need a harmon
figure because you drove through
such change and i think we've got a
picture somewhere
of uh
1997 and blair's babes do you remember
that can you see yourself there do you
remember that green yes yeah yeah with
tony blair and there's the late momolan
in front of you
uh you were behind all women's
shortlists what was it like back then
when you had this breakthrough
i think it was incredible because it was
a time when
women were just saying we're fed up with
being regarded as second-class citizens
you know we're fed up with the idea that
you know men should run the show and
women should abide by everything that
men say
and that we were fed up with being
excluded from you know all walks of life
including political journalism um and
so to have that breakthrough and to have
women in the house of commons
representing a country which is 50 women
was a very important moment and you know
as we went around you know if you went
to the supermarket or you just went out
and about in the street people would
come up and say it's fantastic women
would come up and say it's fantastic to
see you there in the house of commons
because otherwise previously had just
been a sea of great grey suits there was
97 men and only three percent women i
mean and parliament was just downright
unrepresentative and that affected the
public policy agenda you know we've
still got
a way to go um yeah we've still got a
way to go and women are really on equal
terms the obvious question there's no
ever been a female leader of the
labour party the conservative party had
two female prime ministers you know
some people might say that labour has a
bit of a woman problem is that fair well
we certainly got a woman problem in
terms of never having a woman leader
which is downright embarrassing and next
time although we're not going to be
having a leadership election any time
soon next time we do need a woman leader
but that's how would your money be on
oh i you know honestly i'm not gonna i'm
gonna let the future mps and you know
party members choose that but the other
thing is it can't be taken away from
labor that we did lead the way
and we did by ensuring we had all those
labour women mps then the other parties
began to look quite old-fashioned as men
only preserves so they followed in that
path let's move on to another area um
which i know you've campaigned on and
can care deeply about which is violence
against women and girls because again
this is a very
poignant and
relevant issue at the moment
we've recently had the anniversary of
the abduction and murder of sarah
everett that moment that lit a touch
paper in this country where thousands of
women came out to protest against
violence against women and girls rape
cases at a record light high
prosecution's a record low
when i interviewed the home secretary
she said all of us at some stage in our
lives have been subject to all sorts of
harassment is she right have you
i think there's not a woman in this
country who hasn't at some point at some
part of her life been followed down the
street um been harassed
on public transport
have been
sexually harassed at work i mean it's
just every woman's universal experience
and what's happening now
oh i mean i was
sexually harassed at work when i was a
trainee solicitor you know like every
school girl if i walked down the street
i was always looking over my shoulder
and
you know men would follow along in cars
and that's still happening today but
what is different today is that women
are rightly saying we're not going to
put up with this anymore we want curb
crawling to be an offense we don't want
there to be impunity for men um who rate
women and say well she said no but she
actually meant yes so i think that what
is
really important now is that women are
no longer prepared to put up with what
all of us have put up with
and also
that
when i was being sexually harassed at
work in my 20s
there was no question of any complaint
about it absolutely what did nothing
said nothing to anybody what did you do
to the man or what did you just try and
avoid him or well i i shrieked because
he kind of came up and grabbed me from
behind
and but it wouldn't have occurred to me
to be able to complain because he was
senior
and
was you know my sort of line manager and
my future
career completely dependent depended on
not being chucked out and all the
partners would have sided with him and i
would have been regarded as a
troublemaker it's the same old same old
story that every woman do then just
avoid him yeah just yeah just be well
it's sometimes very difficult to avoid
somebody especially you have to work in
the same room as them just the two of
you on your own but i think the thing is
now that there are an expectation
there's an expectation there should be
complaint systems that they should be
independent that women can complain
anonymously so that they don't expose
themselves to victimization and that
they shouldn't have to be frightened on
the street and people talk about women
not feeling
at risk but it's women are at risk so
what needs to be tackled
is the sense amongst men that they can
harass women and that that's just banter
or they can get away with it and harriet
finally let's let's come on to
uh
you and your decision to step down
um
you announced in december you're going
to step down after 42 years of being an
mp
um and then since you took that decision
obviously your world was turned upside
down uh with the sudden loss of your
husband and fellow mp jack jeromey and i
i want to say again how sorry we we all
are thank you about that harriet um a
week ago there was the by-election in in
birmingham birmingham ardenton which was
was jack's seat was that was that really
difficult for you how was that i think
it would have been really difficult if
we hadn't have won the seat and returned
a labour mp i mean jack was born and
brought up a catholic and he always said
he was lapsed but he never quite got
beyond the notion of an afterlife and
i'm sure he he certainly would be
thinking he was up there looking down
and he would have
been horrified if there'd been anything
other than a labor mp following in his
footsteps so
um
it's good to welcome paulette as as the
new labour mp and just and just on your
on jack you're enduring decades of a
long partnership you've got three
children you've got five grandchildren
you just told me you've got a sixth on
the way so you're going to be very busy
jack described you quite rightly as the
outstanding parliamentary feminist of
her generation and he said he was in all
of you
while you in the house of commons
you talked about jack being a superpower
who made us all walk taller and feel
stronger
does the strength of what you had
together kind of give you the strength
to affect to face the future now because
it must be
very discombobulating but i think if
you've lived with that sort of domestic
propaganda it can't help but you know
reinforce your confidence and all of us
get imposter syndrome from time to time
and think that we can't do things so to
have that relentless
positivity and belief
uh is incredible but it wasn't just me
that was the beneficiary of that
positivity and belief that there are you
know women in the trade union that he
worked in
other women in parliament that he would
always be encouraging because he
believed that a role of men was to
support and encourage women and not to
stand in their way and and hold them
back so
i am left with surely that confidence
that has been built up all of those
years but you know we were together for
for 47 years uh which is an incredibly
long time to share your political
journey and your life's journey with
somebody
and
the thing about being a widow after a
long marriage is that i mean my mum
lived till she was a hundred so i might
have another 30 years left so this is a
new chapter in my life which i've got to
figure out
how to crack on with the things that i'm
going to be doing for the next 30 years
and you know people say oh now that
you're on your own but
i'm i'm not with jack anymore but i'm
not on my own i've got my children i've
got my friends i've got my work
colleagues
and
i don't agree with the notion that
somehow that's out there that
when you're a widow
your life is effectively over that the
best years of your life are behind you
and somehow you're a lesser person
i think that we've got to recognize that
it's a different stage of life
and obviously it starts with great grief
and loss
but
people can be you know they are
themselves in widowhood same as they are
themselves
at the rest of their life
and has it changed how you
approach stepping down as a
parliamentarian because presumably
your next 30 years are going to be
different now did you think about
carrying on working no i haven't changed
my mind about standing down i've been an
mp for for decades and for each day of
those decades i felt a great sense of
responsibility for my constituents for
my role in parliament but at the end of
the day you can't carry on indefinitely
and i want to go when i'm still fully
committed and doing the job to the best
of my ability and you know i'll see
what's on the other side of stepping
down from having those magic letters mp
after my name well i'm sure that you
will be doing many more interesting
things and i think your grandchildren
can be keeping you very busy anyway
harriet thanks so much for coming on the
show